tokyo vice is a gritty neo-noir crime
thriller that digs into the underbelly
of tokyo's warring yakuza clans and asks
the question can ansel elgort sing i did
musicals
as of the writing of this video season 2
has not been confirmed but holy crap
does this ending leave us with a lot of
setup for a potential second round so in
this video we'll be taking a look at
season 1 some of those details you
missed and theories for season 2. and be
sure to like and subscribe because if i
don't film my light quota sado is going
to be very disappointed when he comes
collecting this is jake adelstein the
first foreign hire at macho shimbun the
world's largest paper with a daily
reader base of 12 million macho isn't a
real paper in japan in fact many of the
names of companies and characters
throughout the season have been changed
so it's likely this is based off yomiuri
which once held the guinness world
record for most red newspaper jake has
left his life in missouri to get away
from the pain of his family in episode 3
we learn his dad disowned him and his
sister tried to kill herself my father
you just wish would shut up with the
high expectations and disown me already
my mom
can't accept my little sister is not
going to try to kill herself again so
every call she makes to me is full of
guilt so jake runs as far as he possibly
can to tokyo japan the theme of the
runaway is something found in many of
our characters in one way or another sam
porter the nightclub hostess ran away
from her controlling father and life as
a mormon sato ran away from his life as
the son of a poor fishmonger hoping to
make a name for himself as a member of
the yakuza not only do these characters
share a propensity to run away but
they're all extremely ambitious jake
studies his ass off for years learning
japanese and immersing himself in the
culture to get a chance to join the best
newspaper in the world even when he gets
the job he continues to strive for
excellence wanting to one day become a
renowned investigative journalist but as
jake will find out things work
differently in japan the police and
yakuza work in tandem to keep a tenuous
veil of peace things like honor and
shame play a much larger factor in
people's lives than they do in north
america and getting what you want
sometimes means making deals with
notorious gangsters so jake has to
navigate this new world on top of being
a gaijin a japanese term for outsider
it's actually a good way to unravel the
story as we many of us outsiders to
japanese culture experience the
narrative mainly through his eyes to
make matters more difficult 1999's tokyo
is one in which jake and his boss amy
must navigate a world of racism and
misogyny although amy is a colleague
because she is a woman she is expected
to pour drinks for the men at business
functions she must repeatedly fend off
men's advances and stays at work longer
to prove that she has what it takes to
compete with the men jake straight up
was almost fired day one for just being
white and all of this can be frustrating
amy and jake find out several police
forces weren't following up on sexual
assault cases and when they brought
forward the story it was buried in the
back of the paper even though it seems
all their work was meaningless amy says
it is but one brick in a wall of
information that one day cannot be
ignored someone has to build a wall of
information story by story until the
facts cannot be ignored and then things
have to change it's this persistence in
the face of adversity that endears us to
many of these characters sam's ambitions
are closely related to taking back
control of her own life they started
when she moved away from her controlling
mormon father to become a missionary in
japan eventually stealing 40 000 worth
of yen from a local mission fund to run
away and start a new life as a hostess
in tokyo there she finds herself under
the control of a new man duke who runs
the onix nightclub but sam wants to one
day run her own club the end of season 1
caesar making a deal with hitoshi ashida
the leader of the chaharikai clan of the
yakuza sam really had no other choice
all the money she was saving was stolen
and no bank would give her a loan to
allow her to make the final payment on
her new club by going into business with
the yakuza it sets up a lot of mess for
season 2 especially considering sato her
former lover will be the liaison between
her and the gang and sato i found to be
the most intriguing character on the
show over the span of eight episodes he
goes from low-level yakuza initiate to
one of ashida's trusted advisors this
was largely in part to sato saving
yashida's life from assassins in episode
5. sato more than any other character
encompasses the theme of choice because
he wasn't really given the choice of
what type of life he'd have as a
youngster he holds the ability to choose
in high esteem this is why he gives the
character koji who he sees a lot of
himself in the choice to leave the gang
even giving him a stack of bills to go
back to his uncle and not take the path
he went down a path that has led him to
murder sato also sees himself as a
protector he protects koji by letting
him go and sam from the man threatening
to turn her back into her parents with
him now in charge of sam's new club it
could put him in a precarious situation
does his loyalty lie with the yakuza or
the woman he loves at the end of the
season he is brutally stabbed by fellow
chaharikai member jen the same one he
beat the crap out of in episode 3. i
really hope this isn't the end for sato
i think his journey is far from over and
that he's one of the most interesting
characters on the show but the main
thread at the end of the season revolves
around sam's missing friend paulina and
the yakuza running a sex slave ship
called the yoshino throughout the season
jake has tried to link the yakuza with
its criminal activity but at almost
every turn he reaches a dead end
literally there's a dead body almost
everywhere he goes jake has even made
dangerous alliances with ishida of the
jihari kai clan to bring down one of the
most notorious yakuza leaders tazawa
just like the mafia has several
quote-unquote families so does the
yakuza have several clans these clans
work together and control various
territories however to zawa knowing
ishida is weak and thinking that he's
outdated in the way he thinks wants to
take control over his territory and risk
a clan war which neither the police or
other yakuza clans want the difference
between tuzaw's clan and the jiharikai
is made quite clear tezawa has no moral
code he runs a business that profits off
stealing life insurance policies of
people who commit suicide buys meth from
the north koreans and runs an illegal
sex slave ship as ashida tells jake of
tezawa
is a
virus jake is given a tip for mashida
that one of tezawa's drug planes is on
its way but when they go to investigate
it it's empty but little does jake know
that his friend in the police jin
miyamoto has been working with tazawa
katagiri will soon uncover this
treachery and use miyamoto to entrap
tezawa but tazawa is one step ahead at
the end of season 1 category believes
he's going to uncover a huge drug deal
implicating tuzawa but finds no such
deal instead tazawa himself is there
with a threat stop looking into him or
katagiri's family will be killed and
miyamoto likely dead as tezawa says he's
somewhere quote where his conscience
won't be an issue to him or a liability
to me jake is also confronted with a
dilemma at the end of the season his
father who disowned him wants him to
come home and his sister who he adores
is gravely ill will he go back or will
he stay and investigate polina's
disappearance and i think we get our
answer when a mysterious vhs tape
appears with the title yoshino on it is
security camera footage of paulina
working as a sex worker where she is
brutally beaten for not engaging in
sexual acts this is all part of a
supposed deal she made with tozawa clan
for not paying her debts it's a bit
unclear but i think the footage implies
that she was murdered upon watching it a
few times you can see polina hit her
head forcefully on this table and then
become unresponsive on the floor from a
plot perspective her being dead deepens
the stakes of the story so while there's
a chance she's still alive i believe the
more interesting narrative choice for
the writers here is to have her killed
sam will want revenge she'll probably go
to sato and get the chaharikai involved
then we have jake teaming up at the end
of the episode with katagiri they had a
falling out a few episodes ago when jake
went behind katagiri's back and told
miyamoto about the drug plane even
though katagiri said he should wait now
if we're to look at the events of this
season in a chronological order you
might be surprised the furthest in this
timeline that we go this season happens
in episode one the first five minutes of
this episode actually occur two years
after the events of season one here we
find jake working alongside katagiri
meeting the yakuza's second ranking
member and this actually gives us some
clues as to where season 2 is headed
jake is told to stop investigating to
zala perhaps he's working alongside
katagiri because he's working on a story
that could take to zawa down regardless
if he continues with the investigation
he's told it will result in the death of
his family because this takes place two
years in the future we know that tazawa
is still alive over the course of the
season we've seen him battling an
unknown illness this may have something
to do with his liver as he's told
multiple times from his doctor not to
drink he has a spider angioma on his
face often caused by cirrhosis of the
liver and the ultrasounds done on his
body are around where his liver would be
the real character he's based off of
also died to liver complications at the
end of season 1 dezawa tells his
mistress that he's going to be around
for a very long time perhaps his disease
is in remission which is why we see him
drink a glass of alcohol with a grin on
his face as his final shot whatever the
case may be it looks like he's alive and
well two years in the future and for the
events of season two i thought this
season finale was a great mix of
answering some questions while setting
us up for even greater drama and
intrigue in season 2. i do hope this
show gets renewed it's been one of my
favorites of the year so far behind
severance but i want to hear what you
guys think what are your thoughts and
theories and does it deserve a season
two leave your comments below thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember
i feel good